es una tasa de vacunación con la que
muchos países sueñan más del 86 por
ciento de los italianos han recibido al
menos una inyección contra el hobbit 19
así que para la mayoría de los
trabajadores presentar la prueba de
vacunación o un test negativo ahora
obligatorios será una mera formalidad
todos mis trabajadores y yo estamos
vacunados pero por interés personal no
por política ni nada parecido
exigido desde junio para lugares de ocio
y ahora ampliado a todos los
trabajadores del sector privado y
público el conocido como pase verde es
una medida con respaldo popular los
sondeos muestran que dos de cada tres
italianos están a favor en un país que
se vio muy afectado durante los primeros
meses de la pandemia
en una empresa tan grande como esta es
probablemente una de las principales
cosas que nos protege a todos estoy
definitivamente a favor de ello creo sin
embargo italia enfrenta protestas por la
medida los trabajadores de los
principales puertos amenazan con huelgas
indefinidas a pesar de que a muchos se
les han ofrecido pruebas gratuitas de
kobe 19 para obtener el código qr
necesario las huelgas prolongadas o los
bloqueos violentos podrían generar
problemas en un sector ya escaso de
personal o causar retrasos en la entrega
de mercancías en toda italia por lo que
los estibadores y camioneros podrían
utilizar el pase sanitario para hacer
presión política importo viene el puerto
se utiliza para otros fines sin tener en
cuenta el daño que hace a sus familias
no pensando al daño que cargan al el oro
familia el pasado fin de semana las
protestas contra el pase sanitario ya
desataron violencia en roma después de
quien militantes de extrema derecha se
unieran a los 10.000 manifestantes estos
violentos disturbios han llevado a pedir
la prohibición de los grupos
neofascistas en italia